Mike hence who is also running for
president put out an ad where he hits
Biden over gas prices so far so good
makes sense but they decided they wanted
to get Pence on film at the gas pump and
that's where things get a little bit
confusing let's watch the set hey
everybody Mike Pence here
remember two dollar a gallon gas I do
and then Joe Biden became president of
the United States and launched his war
on energy since that time gasoline
prices are up 60 percent electricity
prices are up 25 Joe Biden's war on
energy is cost
Mike Pence about to drive down the road
and break down when he runs out of gas
because he didn't pump any gas there